>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hi, everyone.
My name is Betsy Peterson,
and I'm the Director
of the American Folk Life Center.
And on behalf of the staff
at the center, the librarian
and everyone here, we're so
thrilled that you're here today.
This is a very special
event, and I'm really excited
about the panel coming up.
This is part of an event called
Dancing Ireni, Reimaging,
Reimagining, Alan Lomax's
choreometrics project.
We're delighted to be
cosponsoring today's symposium
with the University of
Maryland School of Theater,
Dance and Performance Studies.
And today's conversation
is the first part
of a very important landmark
three day conference that's coming
up on choreometrics.
The remaining two days are going to
be held free of charge to anyone,
the public, everyone, at
the University of Maryland.
So please talk to Karen Kohn Bradley
if you're interested in attending
and finding out more about it,
but please join everyone there
if you don't have any plans.
I'm certainly going to be there.
The event today is also part of an
ongoing lecture series that we have,
the Benjamin A. Botkin
lecture series.
And this is a series that allows
the American Folk Life Center
to present the latest and
best scholarship in folklore
at the musicology, cultural
studies and the like.
And it accomplishes two purchases.
The first, sharing all of this
great research and information,
but it also allows us to
enrich our own collections.
And in fact, the conversation
that we're going to be privvy
to over the next couple
of hours will be recorded
and put online eventually available
to people throughout the world
and to people in future generations.
So with that said, let me ask you
if you have any electronic devices
at the moment, any
phones and the like,
if you could please turn them off
or you will be part of our archive.
And finally, this is like a perfect
trifecta of activity going on.
But today's event is not only one
of the Benjamin Botkin lectures,
it's also part of a year-long
celebration of Alan Lomax
on the occasion of the
centennial of his birth.
So happy birthday.
The Alan Lomax collection is one
of ASC's largest most prestigious
and most celebrated collections.
And although Lomax is -- most
of his work is well known,
certainly particularly
the Anglo-American
and African-American work, there
are other aspects of his collecting
and his scholarship that
is not as well known.
And this is particularly true of
his work on dance and dance theory,
to which he devoted a significant
portion of his later career.
The study of dance is formalized
culturally, conditioned,
communicative behavior based on
researching the diversity of dance
and it's relationship to different
cultures throughout the world,
a field which he christened
choreometrics has been
unduly neglected.
As was true with so many important
researchers, Alan Lomax did not work
in isolation and indeed throughout
his entire career he worked
with a range of collaborators
and colleagues.
And choreometrics is no different.
Lomax launched the enormous
choreometrics project in 1965
with collaborators Irmgard
Bartenieff and Forrestine Paulay.
We are delighted to have
Forrestine Paulay here with us today
for today's discussion as well
as choreometrics project
researcher, Meriam Lobel.
But before I turn the proceedings
over to Karen Kohn Bradley
who is the Director of
Graduate Studies and Dance --
I'm sorry, Chair of Graduate
Studies and Dance School of Theater,
Dance and Performance Studies
at the University of Maryland
and lead organizer
of this conference,
I just want to thank you again for
all coming and invite you to join
in on the conversation after,
when we open things to the public
and to please stay for
the reception afterwards.
So without further
adieu, I will turn things
over to Karen Kohn
Bradley who is right there.
[ Applause ]
>> Welcome everybody.
It's thrilling for me to see these
faces here, coming from so far away.
I am here to do the thank you.
I have so many people to thank.
I made a list.
First of all, of course, the
American Folk Life Center,
the Library of Congress,
particularly Betsy Peterson,
Todd Harvey, Nancy Gross [assumed
spelling], Thea [assumed spelling],
everybody whose been
so helpful here.
The School of Theater, Dance
and Performance Studies,
who for whatever reason awarded me
the Dorothy G. Madden Professorship
of Dance, which allowed
me to play in a sandbox
that I never could
have afforded otherwise
and to bring everybody
together for this conference.
I'm so grateful for
the opportunities.
The Association for Cultural Equity,
particularly Anna Lomax Floyd
who we've been having a conversation
for some years now about how
to get this collection out there
digitized, etc. So grateful
to your partnership -- for
your partnership and your help.
And [inaudible] studies in New
York, which I also hang out at.
And I just wanted to do a
shout out to my students
who have been working
on this project.
Du [assumed spelling] Barker,
can you raise your hand?
Christina [inaudible], Megan
Boden [assumed spelling], Sinclair
and [inaudible], Kate Spanos.
These are some of the graduate
students from the University
of Maryland who've become engaged
with this work so deeply and fully
and made it their own,
and I feel grateful
for the future of it
because of them.
And finally, my colleague,
Miriam Phillips.
When she first came to the
University of Maryland,
we decided one day
on a lark to go down
and find the choreometrics
materials.
We didn't really know
where they were,
but we came on a subway,
and we came on down.
We went to the Smithsonian first.
And they said, no, no, it's
over at the Library of Congress.
And we walked in, and there was
Todd Harvey and so began this --
I don't know -- six, seven
years of conversation
about how we could do
something with this material.
And today is a launch
of a new stage of that.
So welcome everybody.
Thank you, Miriam.
And I turn it over to you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Miriam Phillips:
And last by not least,
I would like to thank Karen
Bradley whose been the extraordinary
visionary behind this project
and incredibly perseverant
to make even getting
this far happen.
And we have a lot of work to
do, and she's been incredible.
So thank you, Karen, and again
thanks to all of you, Forrestine,
Mary, and everyone because I know
people have been coming from near
and far so we really
appreciate that.
Karen left out one
tidbit of a story.
Along with the time where
we came down here on a whim,
it seemed that it correlated
with the time when the --
at the Lavon Institute,
some of the original files
of Irmgard were also discovered
in a storage unit -- where?
In Brooklyn.
And so it was this kind
of synchronistic timing.
And so it just kind of lit the
fire to progress with this project.
So, I thought that we
would spend half the time.
I have some questions
I thought about before.
Discussing with you and then
open it up to our esteemed guests
for comments, questions, ideas.
Could you each start with telling
us briefly how you got involved
in the choreometrics project?
How did you meet Alan Lomax?
>> Forrestine Paulay: I think
I'll start since I started.
Oh, wow. Alan Lomax was a
student of Ray Birdwhistell.
And when Alan had already developed
the countermetric study, he --
there were certain
questions that he had
that he felt he wasn't
finding the answers
for in the countermetric study.
So he spoke with Birdwhistell,
Ray Birdwhistell, about this --
Ray Birdwhistell was
the founder of kinesics.
And Birdwhistell said, "Well,
dance is a more fundamental,
more primary relative
expression than song.
And if you're going to find out
the answers to the questions
that you're interested in, you're
going to need to look at dance.
And Birdwhistell recommended
[inaudible] analysis
as probably the most appropriate
analysis for discovering the kinds
of answers to the questions
that Alan had.
So Alan called up -- I guess
at that point it was the Dance
Notation Bureau and invited Irmgard
and as a dancer, Irmgard asked
me to come along with her
in this interview with Alan to begin
to discuss whether we thought we
could help him develop a system
for looking at movement
cross culturally.
It turned out to be an extremely
interesting experience at that time
because we were looking from
the [inaudible] analysis point
of view pretty much at individuals.
And this was not going
to answer the questions
that Alan was interested in.
And I can remember that one of the
very first films that we looked
at with the Georgia
Sea Island Dancers,
and Irmgard and I just had a ball.
We had such fun getting the
individual differences of everyone
of the performers, and we
were very excited about this.
And we bring it in to conference
with Alan, and we start talking
about all these differences,
and Alan sort of sits back,
and he said something like, "Well,
that doesn't tell us anything."
And we were just totally
off the mark.
And that began a whole education
for both Irmgard and me in looking
at movement in terms
of dfiferent levels.
And that if we're going to look
cross culturally, we are not looking
at individual differences.
We are not looking at individual --
God, I was just reading something
out there which was
showing the effort shape --
well, not the shape because
that wasn't in there yet,
the effort graph and
changes from free flow
into bound flow light,
back to free flow.
Well, this is not going to make --
give you any information
that's going
to enlighten you about cultures.
All right?
So that began this whole
education of looking
at the whole world of dance.
And one of the first things we
did was collect together reels
that had all of the areas
represented, and looking at that
and beginning to find patterns.
And so the early coding system
came out of that work of looking
across all the different
areas and finding a way
of adapting the Lavon work
to the cultural level.
That was work that preceded
probably up until 1970.
So it was very based
in Lavon's work.
1970, Irmgard went back to
the Dance Notation Bureau
and began teaching there, and Alan
and I continued working
on the coding system.
And that was when we began
looking at and brought
into the system patterns of
social organization and also
such parameters as palm
presentation, use of foot.
So we began to look at how
the body was used generally.
So not specifically oriented
to the Lavon background.
But clearly influenced
by the sensitivity
that a trained person develops by
going through that kind of training.
So that's the beginning.
>> Miriam Phillips: Thank you.
Answers bring up more questions.
But let's here from Mary.
>> Meriam Lobel: Well, I started
out as an anthropology student
in college, and I took a year
abroad, and I went to Greece,
and I was planning to write
something about my experience
in Greece, which was transformative.
But when I was there, I realized
that I couldn't possibly
capture what I wanted to say
about Greek culture and
Greek life in writing
and so I decided I should try
to pursue ethnographic film.
So I came back to New York, and I
wanted to work in ethnographic film,
and I called the only
person I had heard
of whom I thought could help me.
I called Margaret Meade
[assumed spelling].
I said, "I would like to
volunteer as an intern and work
with someone who's doing
ethnographic film."
And she said, "Well, you
should really call Alan Lomax
because he is doing an amazing
project about world dance."
And I was so excited because dance
was also very important to me.
I had been studying modern dance my
whole life as well as in college.
And I called Alan and I said I
was interested in being an intern.
He said, "Okay.
Come on up."
So I went there, and I guess
in the beginning I was working
to help procure the film
from all over the world
and to just keep an organized
catalog of the films from all
over the world and gradually
began working on the coding system
and learning with Forrestine
how to look
at films from all over the world.
And I thought I would show
you just a very short --
it's a six minute film -- that
gives an idea of the influence
that choremetrics played out in my
life since the time I was there.
I was there from 1971 to 1994 on and
off because I -- like many of you --
I was always torn between
researching dance
and being a dance practitioner.
So there were times when
I went back more full time
to studying and performing dance.
And I will just bring
up a few highlights
of the choreometric system
when I show you this material.
I didn't shoot any of it, but these
are all performances that I've seen.
So it starts out -- the first is a
performance that I -- [inaudible].
[ Music ]
One of the things that we looked
at in choreometrics [inaudible].
This is [inaudible].
After I was working with Alan's
project for a couple of years,
and I fell in love with dance all
over the world, I was so excited
to see people dancing
in any culture.
And I went back to finish my
degree at University of Wisconsin,
and I heard that [inaudible] mother
[inaudible] was coming to teach
in Seattle that summer, and I just
couldn't believe that she was coming
to teach, and we would have an
opportunity to study with her.
So I began studying and working
with them for many years.
But again, [inaudible] dancing
illustrates so many things
that are characteristic
of that region,
her use of facial expression,
her eyes, her use of hands,
her interpretive [inaudible].
You don't see it here, but there are
live musicians sitting right next
to her in the room.
Fast forward.
From time to time, my daughter
says, "Oh, mom, [inaudible]."
[ Music ]
What I found is having been
a choreometrics [inaudible].
[ Music ]
For a number of years, [inaudible].
The community there
is largely Latino
so I worked [inaudible]
American musicians and dancers.
And this is [inaudible]
so much African influence
in the way he moved, [inaudible],
his forward posture, [inaudible].
[ Music ]
Most of them -- well, I'll
go back to that later.
But this is the last
piece [inaudible].
This is the Greek parade
in New York City.
Every year around March 25, we
have a parade and [inaudible]
who are marching, emphasizing their
synchrony and the use of their feet,
the complex stepping [inaudible].
They're lifting their legs.
And last but not least, this
is the [inaudible] Greece.
Again, this is what got me to
Alan's office in the first place.
My enchantment, I guess, with
Greek culture and [inaudible] was
such a part of life there.
I think almost every single
night that I was there
in the evening you would see people
in the [inaudible] just getting
up to dance spontaneously.
They enjoyed it so much,
and everybody enjoyed it.
I guess [inaudible].
Again, a wonderful approach to
dance that is such an important part
of people's social lives and
choreometrics [inaudible] synchrony
and the stepping, foot
crossing [inaudible].
[ Music ]
Dancing [inaudible] I'm not
sure where that is going,
but I'm [inaudible] for thinking
of the idea that dance could help
to work to help foster
more peaceful interactions.
[Inaudible] means peace in Greek.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Miriam Phillips: Continue
to reflect on the early days,
when you both met Alan, how did
he describe the project to you?
I mean, what did you understand
this project to be about?
Did he describe it to you?
>> Meriam Lobel: What I was
going to say is Alan lived
and breathed the project.
He was so excited about every
single bit of the research
and every finding and every can
of film that came in from far
and wide across the world.
His enthusiasm was so contagious
and infectious, and he just --
he talked about it all the time so
he didn't really have to describe it
because he was enthusing
about it constantly.
And he was determined and committed,
and he never let anything interfere
with him pursuing it and
trying to fill it out to be
as representative as possible.
>> Forrestine Paulay: I'm trying
to remember how he first
described it to Irmgard and me.
Alan had a passionate love
for what he called the good
and the beautiful.
And I don't really
remember his description.
But what comes to me was the sense
of his love for the performances
of different cultures
around the whole world.
He had such a deep respect for the
integrity of the different cultures
that he was viewing, that
he had been listening to.
And I think what really stayed with
me and what interested me so much
as I began to view the material was
the -- well, from him certainly,
his valuing of each style of
not having a say preference
for the western European
style of which he came.
But that kind of broad appreciation,
and I think that's what's part
of what captured me and made
me want to do the study.
It touched something
very deep in me.
As I watched the dancers
and the dances going by,
I experienced such a sense of
the presence of real humanity
and the expression of the
whole life way of a people
through their performance
style through their dance,
and I could remember being caught by
seeing -- driving down, what was it?
First Avenue or something and seeing
up in a window a group of children
who were studying dance,
and they had scarves.
They were swniging
the scarves like this.
And it was like I saw that, and
then it took me all the way back
into looking at some of the
early English dances and such
where they were swirling scarves.
And it was like the
feeling of continuity
that what we're doing today is so
related to years and years and years
of people living together
that it's not just "dance,"
but it really epitomizes those
things that were important
for the lives of those people
way back, and that's what's part
of my heritage I thought.
It's like here I had
been studying this
and I had no sense of the history.
And this gave me not only a sense
of my own history, but my history
in perspective of the whole world.
And so that's the best answer I
can give to that question of --
that's what I -- it exuded from
Alan, this deep respect and love
of the beauty, the esthetic beauty
of all performances,
of all cultures.
>> Miriam Phillips: It's
bringing up for me a little bit
of what was Alan searching for?
I don't know.
Maybe Anna you can also talk
about this a little bit later.
What was he looking for?
And that he brought
you on just with --
I mean, was there always some
kind of inkling of a theory
or cultural patterns or it
was more just like looking.
Let's see?
>> Forrestine Paulay: He had
done the whole cantometric study.
>> Miriam Phillips: Cantometrics
before, so there was already that?
>> Forrestine Paulay: He had
that model, and he had questions
that he had not yet
been able to answer.
So it was Birdwhitsell saying
no, you've got to look at dance.
And some of those questions had to
do with energy, that he was not --
he wasn't seeing the distributions
that he was curious about,
and the song style
wasn't bringing those up.
So he had -- he had
the whole experience
of using the George Murdock area
files and so he was able to organize
as we got materials --
he had a very clear idea.
He wanted a full world sample
of dance style in order for us
to develop a system that
would be comprehensive
and that would be a
level of observation
that would be applicable a
the cross cultural level.
So there were a lot of
things like when we started
and just wasn't appropriate,
the individual differences.
But it was also true that
there were cultural definers
that also would not be
applicable cross culturally.
So he had a very clear idea as we
were looking, and we were looking
for patterns, that Irmgard and I
immersed ourselves really in all
of the areas and began to get
to know something about them
so that we could begin
to see patterns
that characterized a certain group.
But was that of a particular kind
of phenomena that made some sense
if you used that particular -- those
parameters on different cultures?
On all the different areas?
Was it going to provide some kind
of an interesting distinction?
His guidance was, I mean, essential
in the development of the system
to keep it at the cross
cultural level.
>> Meriam Lobel: I think he
wanted to look at the beauty
of human expression, which we've
all been saying that he loves
and appreciated so much,
and not to have any kind
of hierarchical analysis, and
that was really the beauty
of choremetrics also that
it was just a way of looking
at all different forms of dance with
some parameters that you could use
to hang onto, but there
was no one style,
certainly ballet was not considered
to be the ultimate aspiration
of every dancer in the world.
And that was also what made it so
appealing, that it was very open
and accepting of every dance style.
>> Miriam Phillips:
Great, thank you.
Could you speak a little bit
about what some of the --
your working conditions were?
Take us back to you
showed up at work.
What did you do.
How did these -- how did
these coding sheets develop
and get altered?
I mean, take us through what --
it sounds like probably
there wasn't a typical day,
but I think maybe there was.
>> Forrestine Paulay: Well, it
was a great day when Mary came on.
We needed help.
Or I did certainly at that point.
98th and Broadway.
That was the very first
-- 12th floor --
and it was an apartment that
had been turned into offices,
and one room was for
the cantometric --
all of the materials for
cantometrics for the song materials.
Alan had a large office where he
spent I don't know how many hours,
at least 28 hours every day
of going through all of the --
oh well, the grant writing.
I mean, Alan did all
the grant writing.
He interviewed people.
He made contacts with
people in order to get films
and to get -- to increase
the sample.
He was the person who
was responsible
for determining the whole sample
and was it going to be adequate.
And so he worked in conjunction
with Connie Arensberg [assumed
spelling], would come frequently.
He had a statistician.
Do we have statisticians here?
Well, there was another one, too.
[ Inaudible ]
Ed Erickson [assumed
spelling] was there.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Statistician, Ed Ericson was there.
Norman Berkowitz [assumed
spelling] was there.
Roswell Rudd [assumed spelling]
was there doing the coding
for the cantometrics.
And Irmgard -- well, these
people -- they came later.
They were not apart of this
initial -- was Irmgard and me,
and we had marathons
of looking at footage.
I used to at night I would
dream seeing these dances,
and I would enter into
them and dance with them.
>> Miriam Phillips: I'm sorry.
Did you watch the films
together with Irmgard and then --
>> Forrestine Paulay:
Later Mary came.
>> Miriam Phillips: Right.
>> Forrestine Paulay:
This was the first --
>> Miriam Phillips:
Did you watch together?
Did you watch separately?
>> Forrestine Paulay: Oh no.
We watched together.
And Alan too.
>> Miriam Phillips:
And were you filling
out coding sheets as you went?
>> Forrestine Paulay: Oh no because
we didn't have coding sheets yet.
>> Miriam Phillips: So this was --
>> Forrestine Paulay:
This was pre-coding.
We were just observing and looking
and looking and making notes
and then educating ourselves about
the different levels of observation.
All right?
That was a big part
of the early process.
And we spent hours observing.
I mean, I had at home -- I
would even take things at home,
and I had a machine so I could
run things backward and forward.
And I started dreaming.
I'd watch cars going
across the street
and then I'd watch them backing up
and then I'd watch them go again.
It was like the whole process
-- it felt like pregnancy.
Like I was stretching to take
in this whole world of dance.
It was an amazing experience.
And it was out of that that
gradually we developed a
coding system.
And the coding system
developed by increments.
In the early years, it was more
organized by Lavon's principles.
So we were looking at
dimensionality, right?
We did look at one and
two units of the body.
We looked at various qualities
of say transition in space,
things which were more
related to the Lavon work.
And that was like the
first coding system,
and we went through that and coded.
So It was a gradual development.
Normal Berkowitz would then
take the coding sheets,
and they were transcribed
onto cards,
which Todd was showing me
the cards are even here.
Then they were taken to the Columbia
computer room, big, big, room.
Then we would get back these sheets,
and Alan would spend hours
looking through these numbers.
So excited when one of these things
-- I would look at it -- God.
It was just piles of numbers.
And he was so good at
determining pattern
because he had the whole
ethnography in his head
and so he could immediately
see if pattern was coming
out of particular parameters,
and that helped shape the
development of the coding system.
That was one of the
important pieces.
After Irmgard left, then we
began developing other aspects
of the coding system,
social organization
and body presentation and such.
And at that point I was
handling all of getting the films
and bringing them in and
selecting the sections,
and this is finally
when Mary arrived.
It was marvelous to have another
person there to begin training
to do some of the coding and to
handle because he was starting
to handle this -- because it was
one enormous job was collecting all
the material.
And that was when I was in
the archive just earlier
and saw my hand notes on have
we called so and so and ask Alan
if we can spend $150 on this
particular film from so and so.
And it was a massive job
collecting this footage.
It really was.
And we had to go through it,
and then we had to select
out sections that were
most relevant.
And the other thing that shaped
the coding system that was
so fascinating was it was to find
characteristics which you look
at a small piece of
it, and you've got it.
In other words, so you're not
having to look and detail this
and then come up with a code.
But it has to be conveyed
immediately
because what we're looking
at basically is how cultures
represent themselves.
We're looking at cultural identity.
And cultural identity has
got to be there right away.
You come up to a person and you
recognize am I of this culture?
That takes care of a lot of
things and then you can go
on with other kind of
detailed interaction.
So we had to shape
our way of looking
to capture cultural identity.
So it's an interesting thing.
One of the things that I've noticed
that certain people have talked
about is -- oh, because we were
also looking at every day movement
because we wanted to
see the correlations
between the dance style
and movement.
And there's a real one aspect of the
relationship between the dance style
and the work is that the --
basically this is what
people are doing.
The neurological patterns are
developed from very early on.
And those are brought
forward in the dance.
But there's another aspect
to it and this is identity.
And it's cultural identity.
And that sets the motion
for interaction
and patterns of interaction.
So we were looking.
Can you grasp those things?
So immediately and in ways
that can be taught easily
because we did consensus studies.
Did we do those -- did you cover or
have we already done some of the --
we had already done those.
Okay. We were doing
consensus studies.
So we would bring in students
and teach them some of the lines
and see worthy parameters
that we had developed.
Not only did they provide
interesting information in terms
of the distribution of cultures
but were these lines
teachable and easily teachable.
Could other people besides
trained people see them?
And that also determined
what we kept in the system.
>> Miriam Phillips: Great.
Ask you more of my
questions another time,
but I'm going to keep
the conversation moving.
Mary, tell us a little bit
about when you came on board.
You -- my understanding --
were not formally trained
like certified Lavon movement
system but Forrestine and Irmgard --
>> Meriam Lobel: No.
I wasn't trained.
>> Miriam Phillips: Sort of
trained you in that sense.
Tell us a little bit about
that and what was your role.
>> Meriam Lobel: I think when
I first came in I was helping
in a big way with the films.
I remember some of
the films came in.
We got film from Prince
Peter of Greece and Denmark
and a big [inaudible] wrapped
in his pajamas all [inaudible]
stitched together by hand.
This was a time when we couldn't
send things over the internet.
We got film from India that was
in burlap and also in a container
that was stitched by hand.
So whatever we got, we
were very careful to log,
and we had a pretty
complicated system.
We made notes about
what was on the film.
A lot of times, there was dance, but
there was other material as well,
and we had all kinds of notebooks
where we made notes about that.
We had file cards where we also put
that information and then took a lot
of the film down to a lab in
midtown and had copies made,
work copies of the dance
sections that we knew
that we were going to be coding.
So there was a lot of
processing in that way,
and then when we started putting
together the choreometric films,
I also spent a lot of time -- I
was the assistant editor on those
with trying to figure out what
clips we were going to use
and using [inaudible]
to cut it frame by frame
and syncing up the music.
So there was quite a
bit of film work going
on in conjunction with
the dance coding.
As I was there, Forrestine
taught me the coding system,
and we worked together a lot
for long hours every day,
and it was just fascinating.
And we would discuss
what we saw and whether
or not we were both
seeing the same thing
and then what the findings were
that were coming out of it.
But Alan also was doing
his own larger analysis
of the findings cross culturally.
I think based on his
cantometrics findings.
>> Miriam Phillips: Tell us a
little bit about the findings.
I mean, I'm really curious.
Did you have -- can you
recall like an aha moment?
I'm sure you had many aha moments.
Or, well, I'll let you
[inaudible] that one.
>> Forrestine Paulay: Yeah, yeah.
There were -- I mean -- it was
such an education in anthropology.
I mean, coming out from
the perspective of a dance,
choreographer, it was a constant
source of almost like wonder
that the use of the body
or the use of space related
in say some instances
to technology so that --
I mean, the one dimensionality
being related to a particular kind
of tool used that if you're
using say a wooden tool,
if you were to use it with a
curve, you would probably break it.
And so watching Australian
aborigines working on say a tree
with a wooden tool, and the kind of
patience and the kind of repetition
that was required with those
reversing one dimensional movements,
right, in contrast to where they
had metal and seeing the sweep
of the metal blade
cutting the harvest
and seeing how this
really did shape the dance.
I think it's just really seeing
the significance of that that was
so impressive and I mean, the fact
that would be one level of aha.
But another level of aha would
be to see the distribution
of a particular pattern
-- say the one unit torso,
and to see that across the whole
pacific and see it going all the way
down right into the
tip of South America.
Or to see that in the use of
horses, it's not only in the use
of the stirrup but where
there's no stirrups,
where it's basically at
the tip of Patagonia.
I think it's the [inaudible].
Interesting how things
start coming back.
I think it's the [inaudible]
indians who dance on [inaudible].
They are a horse culture
that was so indomitable
that I think they were
maybe the one cultures
that was never taken over,
was never by Europeans.
And they danced on [inaudible].
American indians.
Not the [inaudible].
The importance of horses, and
you take that and you think
of the Georgian dancers
who are dancing on toe.
So there's something besides
the actual movement patterns
that are being conveyed
through the dance.
But there is an identity with
horses and meaningfulness of horses
where the use of the foot
is like the use of a hoof.
So it shows something more about
the complexity that we're looking
at when we're looking at a dance
because it isn't just these
are the movement patterns
that the culture survived on,
but these are the identifications
that these people made with
those things that are important
in their lives which adds
another level of richness.
And it adds another level of
richness for dance teachers
to understand when you're working
what's the cultural identity
like for the person you're
teaching and you're working with?
And how do you -- how do you teach?
How do you use this choreometrics?
In order to help people really
experience a shift in identity,
a shift in cultural identity,
what can you do through movement
which means drawing on your other
kinds of backgrounds in movement,
to bring to the dancers so they
can actually experience oh,
if you start working through the
feet, you're going to get something
in the upper body that
if you go directly
to the upper body you're not
going to get because so often
and what we see, say why
it looks so different
to see the early Caucasians doing
multiunit style and why it looks
so stiff, look at their feet.
You've got to work through the feet.
You have the whole barefootness,
all right, that goes along
with the multiunit style.
And it's because the flow comes
from the foot all the way up.
And if you put a shoe on that foot,
and you don't teach that person,
you know, you can't go
even if you're barefoot
as if you have shoes on, you're
not going to get the fluidity
in the multiunitness of the body.
I think I may have went off a little
bit from that, but the question --
>> Miriam Phillips: Interesting.
Let me ask Mary something
about the work process,
and then I have two more
questions and I want to open it up.
So you're observing, you're doing
-- when the coding sheets came on,
you're doing the coding sheets.
You're giving them back to Alan.
They're going in the mainframe.
These numbers get spitted out.
Well, just that process.
How you were sort of feeding things
into Alan, what he was getting
and then the interpretations
that started coming back to you.
>> Meriam Lobel: We were
all in the same small office
so we would code a few things.
>> Miriam Phillips:
Would he code with you?
>> Meriam Lobel: No.
Well, sometimes he sat there.
Then we would go and discuss with
him something or give him a stack
of coding sheets that we had just
done, and we would talk about it
and then he was really
giving it to --
after we got a certain amount
done and then feeding it
to whoever was analyzing
it through the computer,
through the global jukebox.
The last time that
I was working there,
he was trying to accumulate a
certain number of codings and also
to reduce the number of
parameters on the coding sheet
so maybe there could be 40 different
parameters instead of the four pages
of codes that we were
putting in for awhile.
He was trying to -- working
with you also, Forrestine --
trying to find what were the
most essential characteristics
that could speak to the essence of
the dance of the use of the body,
the social organization or the
relationship to the audience,
the dynamics of the movement.
What could be the minimum number
of variables that you could look at
and still get something
meaningful from it?
>> Forrestine Paulay:
He was actually doing factor
analysis work on that.
So it would not -- it
wasn't just by looking
and saying well let's
put this together.
He would do factor analysis and
that would bring pieces together
and sometimes what would then
happen is then we would take
that factor analysis
and actually out of
that sharpen the coding parameter.
So that became the part of the
progression of the coding sheet
so that there was a
constant interplay of the --
sort of the statistics
and the technology
with the observations
shaping the coding system.
>> Miriam Phillips:
Now, at some point,
there was some interpretations of
all the patterns that were started
to be made and once the -- I guess
it was the film started coming out
and publications, there
was some controversies
that came up with the project.
Were you -- did they come
into your conversations?
And that will be coming
up over the next few days,
I think, in some conversations.
But did those come back to
you in the conversations?
>> Meriam Lobel: I could say
something because at the time
that I started working there, the
field of anthropology was changing
and anthropologists felt
that they really needed
to specialize very much in one
specific culture and perhaps
in one specific village
within one country.
And so I always felt there
was a lot of resentment.
I don't know if that's the
right word, but people didn't
like the fact that Alan thought
that he could look an objective way
at a bigger global picture.
And it really didn't
-- from what I heard,
it really didn't even have
anything to do with knowledge
of what the project
was actually doing.
It was the fact that he was saying
that it was possible to look
at the world of dance
in a global way.
And I disagreed with the people
who felt that it was not possible.
I think his intellectual
capacity and his vision
and his thoroughness -- it was just
so huge that he could do something
and I think he gave all of
us tools that we can utilize
to help us all understand
each other and the ways
that we organize socially
in different types of groups
and the way that we move and
the way we use our bodies.
But I think it was very
much a trend of othe times.
In all kinds of science, of
course, there were people --
there was a time when
feminism was going full force.
So if there was any comment in
any of the choreometric material
that I don't know, reflected any
kind of male attitude towards women,
people always just made a
bee line toward that comment
and completely ignored the
rest of the information
that was being presented.
But so I'm not sure if that's
what you mean by controversy,
but I think those were the two
biggest areas that I was aware of,
and I felt that the
project was so valuable,
and I respected people's
criticisms what they were saying,
especially the first one that
I mentioned where anthropology
as a field was the whole
time of being so embarrassed
about American colonialism and
how dare we presume to be able
to say anything about anybody else
in the world, and who are we go
to somewhere and tell people
that this is what you're
thinking and feeling.
So everybody was just trying
to work on a very micro level
and report every little
thing that was going
on in a specific cultural
environment,
and Alan was in the midst of
working in a more global way.
>> Miriam Phillips: Right.
I mean, some of the commentary
was about the decontextualization
or some of the interpretation sort
of that was aboutp a particular
group representing a whole culture.
So yeah, did those -- did that come
into your conversations at all?
>> Forrestine Paulay: Well
it did certainly with Alan.
I mean, we did discuss that.
But the thing is, any
dance performance --
you can look at it from
so many different levels.
There's such richness there,
and I think people felt
that richness was getting slighted.
I remember talking with someone, and
it was about -- what group was it?
But it was east European dance.
I don't know.
They were talking about --
this is an exaggeration because
I don't remember the number --
but anyway, something like well,
there are 600 different steps,
and you're calling this
step style and stepping.
And -- but there are
600 different ones.
They have -- they're done
in different occasions
and by different people.
And to explain that, that is
beautiful and it's very interesting.
But that's not the level
that we're observing on.
We're looking at the
difference between this kind
of stepping pattern that crosses
like this and a stepping pattern
which maybe just walks
forward and never crosses.
And that makes it an important
distinction at this broad level.
But it certainly leaves out a
wealth of beautiful information
and important information
about the culture.
It's just that wasn't the
level we were looking at.
So there was not an understanding
frequently, I think, about that.
And possibly, it wasn't presented --
I could see that it could be really
interesting to show the simplicity
of what the choreometrics level
was getting at then have someone
from the culture show the
amount of diversity within that
so that both could be
shown to people at the --
in continuity so that it's like --
it's not for lack of
appreciation of that.
But if you get caught in
that, it was like when Irmgard
and I first got caught in
individual differences.
They're very interesting
if you're going
to do a psychological
study of those people.
But it's not going
to tell you anything
about where they are in the world.
>> Miriam Phillips:
Well, it kind of gets
into my last question before opening
it up, which is what are your hopes
and dreams for this project?
What would you love to see happen?
>> Meriam Lobel: I'm just so
thrilled that Karen and you
and the University of
Maryland are really interested
in bringing this material back
to the attention of students
and young people and also thrilled
that the material is housed
so beautifully at the
Library of Congress.
Your archive is mind blowing really
to see how well everything has
been organized and contained.
So my hope is always that
more people would benefit
from choreometrics and would
appreciate it and have a chance
to look at all of that amazing film
footage of dance all over the world.
My fear in the 70's was always
that all of the individuality
and different cultures was going to
get eradicated, and we would all end
up moving in similar way
and maybe we'll all end
up just thumbing on our phones.
But I think that choreometrics can
really open up the horizon again
to everybody, to dancers and
nondancers about what the range
of possibility is and that
exists in human movement.
>> Forrestine Paulay: I too really
appreciate what's being done here
and what's being done by Karen
and what's being done
by the archivists here.
I was extremely touched by
going down to the archive
and seeing the incredibly
sensitive, intelligent,
loving kind of work
that's been done here.
I think what's touching me
now is these young students
that I'm starting to
meet, and I'm really --
I'm eager to talk to
them about what their --
what's catching them at this time.
What's interesting them?
Why are they doing this?
What does it capture in them that
they're devoting themselves to this?
What have they discovered here?
There's something about the
enthusiasm that touches me.
I feel it's bringing this
work -- it's bringing --
they're bringing the aliveness to
this work that is touching something
in me in terms of vision.
Where are they going to go with it?
And what are they going to do?
And how is it going to spread?
What is the personal
meaning in their lives?
And how can they -- how
are they going to share
that and touch other people?
There's -- Alan's vision of the
good and the beautiful is something
that hold dear because of the beauty
of this performance is not
just the beauty of performance,
but it's the beauty of
different life ways.
It's about appreciation
of how people live
and how they communicate.
How do they interact?
How do they make contact?
I think there's something
here in how they make contact
and how they relate that can be
an experiential lession for more
and more people, that there are
different ways of being with others
and to begin to look at that,
there's something about that
when we see this whole world
movement, we can also begin
to see ourselves more clearly.
We can begin to maybe make
more choices about ourselves
when we see ourselves
in perspective.
Because we assume so
much because we just --
that's just the way
things are for us.
Well, we don't recognize
what has shaped that.
And I think recognizing
what shaped that
and what has shaped others gives
us more respect for other people.
So I think there's
a whole thing here
about spreading respect
throughout the world that can come
through the arts through song,
through dance when one sees it
as these are living patterns.
These are patterns that
shape the lives of people.
>> Miriam Phillips: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Meriam Lobel: One little
[inaudible] what you said --
we look at all this footage that
we have in the global jukebox,
and it's from such a
far and wide places
but I remember Alan really took
advantage of wherever he was
to appreciate the different ways
that people express themselves
in song and in speaking, and
he once said to me, "You know,
I do my best research right
now when I take a cab ride."
He said, "You can't believe I spend
the entire ride interviewing the cab
driver and asking him what kind
of music he likes to listen to
and having him sing a song
for me and having him tell me
about his community here
in the United States."
So he was constantly aware and
alert of who was around him
and what they had to
offer artistically,
and I think that's something
that also we can all appreciate
in our own lives by
being more open to that.
>> Miriam Phillips: Absolutely.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Which is following upon what
Forrestine and Meriam just said
that I think the dances
that they studied represent,
and they're not the only
examples, of course,
but kind of the classical
cannon of the world.
And in this era of mixing everything
and taking a little bit from here
and a little bit from there and
saying oh, isn't it wonderful,
we can put it all together,
often times we're doing it
without understanding what
the originalism is about.
When we study art, fine arts, the
visual arts and classical music
and so on, do we not have to go
through years of training for this
and years of study
[inaudible] and so on?
But somehow this sort of
"traditional" forms of music
and dance don't get that.
I think they are now more and more.
There are people who actually
are learning these styles.
But that's not mainly
what's happening,
and I think that it should be part
of our consciousness
and thinking about them.
At least they deserve to
be respected very much
in their own right
first and foremost
because that's the only way we can
really understand and inspect all
of the elements of what they are
and the totality of what they are
and where they come from.
Otherwise, we're just sort
of grazing superficially
and picking off little
pieces of things,
and we don't want to do that.
>> Miriam Phillips: Anna Lomax Wood.
What questions, comments
do you have, Paul?
There's a microphone coming.
>> Hi, thank you.
I had a question or a series of
questions actually all related
to the procuring of the films
themselves because it seemed
like there's a great difference
completely understandably
in the type of films that were
used that you were analyzing.
Some seemed ethnographic.
Some were documentaries.
Some seemed like they
were folk performances
where others might have been
part of a festival or tradition.
So how did you identify the films?
Did you rely on people overseas
to make selections of those films?
I loved hearing how some
came, how they arrived.
But how did the conditions
of their production figure
into the way you analyze them
or into the way Alan actually
interpreted them afterwards?
In other words, because
there's a disparity in the films
which I actually think makes for
richer interpretation actually,
but how did that actually
play into the way that --
or did it -- into the
interpretation?
>> Forrestine Paulay: The
interpretation was not of the films.
The interpretation
came out of the data.
And out of the having
the full sample.
That's where the interpretation
came from.
And much of that was not -- I
wouldn't call interpretation.
That was relying the coming
together of the different lines,
what they did in terms
of distributions.
So I can't think what the
right word is at the moment,
but it's not interpretation.
It was really more exposition
of the findings rather
then "interpretation."
In other words, this particular
quality of movement is found
in this particular
distribution around the world.
And that's the first film that
we did which was the Dance
in Human History shows
that graphically.
We -- I tried to minimize
interpretation and stick
with what is the distribution
and the potential significance
of that distribution in
relationship to the Murdock sample
and other things in anthropology
that had been looked at
and where the distribution
had been studied.
As far as the search for films,
the criteria was what geographic
region did they illustrate?
Was there enough footage that
we could get a coding from it?
Did the camera person stick
with some of the European stuff
so that we only had head shots and
couldn't tell much of anything else?
Did they go beyond the
traditional eight second shot
so that we could see
what was happening
without cuts constantly, constantly.
So we looked for anything we could
find from the different cultures
and sometimes that
would be raw footage.
Sometimes it would
be completed films.
be at the festival.
But when you're looking at the
cross cultural level, you're looking
at something which we were trying
to develop where you can capture
that identity in a fairly short
period of time so that we had
to rule out a lot of
interesting measures
that would have required
looking at a whole dance.
So we couldn't look at
choreographic structure usually
because we didn't have it.
So we were limited to those
things that we could discover
within a few minutes of footage,
and we would get that footage
from anywhere, from whether
it was a folk performance.
We would try to find examples
that were done by ethnographers,
anthropologists, etc. so that
there was a certain integrity
in the footage that
we chose to work from.
If something was highly westernized,
we would tend not to use it.
So does that answer your question?
>> It does.
But can I -- even more specifically
when you were looking --
it's usual to see that the
vetting process had more to do
with the quality of the
film, not necessarily
where it came from or what --
>> Forrestine Paulay: Well, no.
It's very much where it came
from because Alan was
working to get a full sample.
So where it came from, yes.
And we had to search far and
wide sometimes to find material
to illustrate certain cultures.
So that was there very much too.
>> So you weren't necessarily
seeking specific samples
of particular dances, but you
were reaching out to people
who might have access
to footage of --
>> Forrestine Paulay:
Representing that region.
Yeah. Rather then a specific dance.
Because if we were
working at the right level,
it should pertain pretty
much across dances.
That style should be
visible to enough
of an extent across
different dances.
That's what I was talking about when
one person was saying there's 600
different dances or different
steps, how can you possibly be --
well, because it's going to be
very different from what's done
in southeast Asia and what's
done in South America or etc.
>> Great, thank you.
>> Meriam Lobel: We did have an
ethnographic film specialist,
Emily Dibogard [assumed
spelling] came in at one point.
This was after we had already
collected a lot of film.
But she was very familiar with a
lot of anthropologists who were
out in the field at that time.
And so we wrote letters to
people wherever they were working
and very often they
were very willing
to bring their material
in and share it.
>> Forrestine Paulay: I mean,
they're major collections.
I mean, Penn State had
an incredible collection
and so we really researched the
different archives that existed.
And we traveled.
I mean, I spent hours
and days in the basement
of the [inaudible] cranking out
footage and looking at a little --
this size -- making selections.
So, we went all over
looking for stuff
and found wonderful treasure troves.
I mean, I did something at
the University of Phoenix
and just talking to somebody
in the audience discovered
this whole garage full
of I think it was Central American,
South American footage,
just by luck.
;
>> Miriam Phillips: Other
questions or comments?
Yes?
>> I was really interested when
you were saying the findings
about how the tools and technology
that they used really
influenced the dance.
And so it sounded to me like
that you maybe researched a lot.
You weren't just looking at the
dance, but there's a lot of research
that maybe went on about the culture
separately from the dance in order
to understand and analyze the dance.
So I was wondering if you
could just talk a little bit
about how you prepared
yourself to observe?
Did you try the dances or
physically attempt them or just ways
that you were preparing yourself to
analyze what you were looking at?
>> Forrestine Paulay: Well,
in terms of the technology,
what we did is wherever possible,
we got examples of the major sort
of work patterns in the culture so
that we not only observed the dance,
but we observed work patterns
and also social interactions.
So we would look at every day life.
Whatever footage we could
get hold of for the culture.
So that that was helpful in
finding sort of key body uses
because you'd see, oh, I can
remember it was a Spanish dance,
I think, where we saw them in the
caves with the caskets of wine,
and the barrels have to be turned.
And so you'd see the
women go turn, turn,
walking down this long
line turning the barrels.
Well, what's this?
Above the head?
There you have in the dance.
So it would be that kind of thing.
So the preparation was simply
staying open, seeing what you see
and looking at patterns and
having the patterns work
on you basically rather
then we work on that.
When we worked on that,
it didn't work.
When we opened up and
let it work on us,
then we began to see the patterns.
>> Miriam Phillips: Adair
[assumed spelling], did you -- ?
>> This is, I guess, a followup
question on that in a way.
In terms of -- I'm just curious
about the quantity of films
that are part of this collection and
what would you say the percentage is
that deals with those work patterns,
social interactions,
looking at the cultures?
If you're focused on dance, I'm
assuming that that was the bulk
of what you were looking at.
But how much would you
say is the rest of that?
>> Forrestine Paulay: I
haven't got the foggiest idea.
>> Okay, okay, okay.
>> Forrestine Paulay:
I think maybe --
maybe Todd would have
a better answer.
I just don't remember .
but whenever we could get a
hold of it, we would look at it.
But it's not necessarily in the
collection because we brought stuff
in that we looked at that we
didn't -- we couldn't collect.
I mean, we were limited in what
we could afford to collect.
And I looked through
collections in Europe.
I mean, film upon film.
My developer side is cranking that
machinery and looking at footage.
So I looked at so much, and I
looked at raw footage, so much work,
so much social interaction that
we never copied and brought in.
So it was just sort
of like a memory bank.
What we have, what we don't.
50 years worth.
I can't believe it.
>> Thank you, yes.
>> Miriam Phillips:
We have time just
for one more comment or question.
>> I was wondering if studying the
oral transmission of these dances
and how the people actually
transmitted from a generation
to another could have helped inform
the choreometrics coding system
and if that has been something
that Alan Lomax was
interested in himself?
Interviewing people maybe
understanding what's their emphasis?
What they're looking at?
Or what they're trying when
they're performing themselves?
>> Forrestine Paulay: This would
be a very interesting question
for someone who's looking
within the culture.
Cross culturally what we
did see and what we did look
at was again every day movement,
how are babies held during the day?
Are they on their backs in
certain African villages
when the women are working?
And you see this and you
see the babies doing this.
In contrast, in certain American
Indian tribes where they're
in the -- what do they call the --
yes, the swaddling in actual wooden
frame so that the baby's like that
or the Eskimo children where
the mother holds the child
and bounces them up
and down like this.
And you see that child
collecting their energy
into a very clear strong
one unit gravity position,
which is what the men have to do
when they go out and wait on the ice
in order to get a seal, right?
So there's a definite relationship
between how children learn.
We also did look at some
teaching situations generally
in more advanced cultures.
But those we would be looking at the
patterns and see how those relate
to the dance rather then the
interesting question you're asking
about which is how they think about.
That's at the cultural level.
Yeah. I think Anna had
something to say too.
>> Miriam Phillips:
Well, let's -- yes and --
[ Inaudible ]
>> If you go into research,
ethographic research,
you can use this knowledge.
And I often tested it out by
asking people about things like --
I don't remember any
specific examples.
But it's very fascinating
when they confirm
from inside the culture what you're
observing from the choreometric
or cantometric point of view.
It's a way of sort of
testing out these ideas
that actually you can do.
So --
>> Miriam Phillips:
Allegra -- I mean --
>> Particularly interested
in the question.
I don't know what it was that
because what's so exciting here
with this is that it -- the
verbal level doesn't interfere
with the process.
It's the body and the movement
level and you see it carry through.
In today, with a little
bit of watching,
and seeing the fisherman walking
through the water and then seeing
that movement in the
[inaudible] was so exciting
to just see the continuity
that correspondence
that [inaudible] a really important.
>> Miriam Phillips: Thank you.
This is just the beginning.
I'm sorry.
Maybe you can come up after
to ask some questions.
I hope you'll -- first of all,
a lovely reception here
so we do have some time.
And second of all, over the
next couple of days we're going
to be moving over to the
University of Maryland,
and we have both structured
sessions, but also there's plenty
of time to have more discussions
and share ideas and just
to again picking up again
on the last question.
I think part of the -- remember,
this is called Reimagining,
Revisioning and Reimagining.
There's also the level of
bringing back in what do the voices
of the people who are
representing the movement think
about what they're doing
and what they have to say
and to bring some more
context back in.
So I think it's a very exciting time
of mapping a lot of ideas together
and possibilities that we
have now in this 21st century.
So I hope you'll be able to
join us over the next few days.
Thank you so much for
your wonderful memories
and insights, Marie, Forrestine.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.